facebook comes under fire from the
democrat media complex joe biden thinks
about minting a one trillion dollar coin
to avoid the debt ceiling and health
line announces men can get pregnant i'm
ben shapiro this is the bench bureau
show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
i protect my data with a vpn so should
you visit expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment again here is your reminder
every time you connect to an unencrypted
network in cafes hotels airports etc
your online data is not secure any
hacker on the same network can gain
access to and steal all that personal
data we're talking passwords financial
details you name it plus your isp is
gathering all this data on you and then
selling it off and they're making money
off of that that's your data why not
protect it today it doesn't take
advanced technical knowledge for a bad
guy to hack you a 12 year old with some
decent hardware could do it which is why
i use expressvpn expressvpn creates a
secure encrypted tunnel between your
device and the internet so hackers
cannot steal your sensitive data not
only is it incredibly secure it is also
super easy to use just fire up the app
you click one button to get protected
expressvpn works on phones laptops
tablets all your devices so you can stay
secure on the go i use expressvpn
literally every time i go online it's on
my phone it's on my computer and all the
rest secure your online activity the way
i do by visiting expressvpn.com
today that's
expressvpn.com you can get an extra
three months for free that's
expressvpn.com
ben alrighty so yesterday saw this big
senate hearing on facebook and this is
all manufactured now let's just be clear
about this the new democrat media
complex attack on facebook is completely
manufactured there are serious questions
to be asked about how facebook nudges
you in particular directions we've
talked about that extensively on the
show we've talked about how facebook's
news feed is incredibly biased how they
use certain metrics in order to try and
promote legacy media content and
suppress alternative content which is
sort of a newfangled thing because back
in 2015 2016 they really didn't do that
and then there was blowback from the
left and facebook because like all other
major corporations cowardice is a factor
there facebook decided that they were
going to back off and start making
changes to their algorithms to please
the democrat media complex well once you
give an inch they seek to take a mile
and right now
it is perfectly obvious that what the
democrats want is to just control
facebook they don't want to destroy it
they want to hijack it and use it for
their own purposes that is the goal they
don't want to set any sort of neutral
rules by which facebook could be held
accountable or to which facebook could
adjust they don't want regulations that
are clear and transparent what the
democrats want at this point is an
agency that sits over all social media
and then adjudicates on a case-by-case
basis whether social media have met the
demands of democrats that is what they
would like and this is what the media
would like as well because you have to
understand that there is this iron
triangle between the democrats and the
media and the social media sphere and
that iron triangle determines what you
see a huge percentage of americans get
their news online
and this is a newfangled thing this
happened over the course of the last 15
years it used to be even online the way
that you got your news is that you went
directly to the websites that you like
to visit you would bookmark breitbart
you bookmark daily wire you'd bookmark
whatever cnn and new york times you
bookmark it you go directly to the site
then facebook became such a massive
source of aggregated eyeballs that news
outlets started using facebook in order
to promote their news then facebook
started its news feed so now it was a
one-stop shop you would go to facebook
to get your news and facebook would
tailor its algorithms to what you liked
to see so if you were conservative you
were more likely to see links that
you're more likely to click on
and that made sense because it was
supposed to be the town square and in
the town square there were a bunch of
newspapers available and you'd go to the
kiosk that you actually liked and
facebook made it convenient by lining up
the kiosks you liked near where you were
entering the town square that's
effectively how facebook's news feed
operated democrats saw however that
facebook had re-established a
distributional monopoly and now because
everyone was getting their news via
facebook this meant that they could turn
off the spigot on people they didn't
like and facebook decided that in order
to please the democrats they were going
to go ahead and start to do this around
the edges and more and more openly
so it started off as sort of a fringe
phenomenon and then it became part of
their mainstream and how they
manipulated the news feed that's a real
concern and it's something that i've
talked about but democrats aren't
satisfied with that what democrats would
like is a standard set by the federal
government that is no standard at all
what democrats actually want
is a
radically
non-it
equality-based standard they want no
neutral standard they want to just be
able to control
essentially what they would like
democrats is to appoint somebody like
kara swisher as the head of a government
agency that oversees facebook and tells
facebook what to do
that's what they would like to do they
would like to seize the means of
distribution
and now if you did this openly it would
be illegal okay if the democrats were
simply to pass a law saying we are going
to control facebook like top to bottom
that would be illegal and the reason it
would be illegal is number one it would
be a seizure of private property without
just compensation and number two
you cannot actually control distribution
of speech in that way the first
amendment prevents that sort of stuff so
democrats are seeking to find another
way of doing that and so what they are
claiming as they always claim is that
facebook is doing grave harm grave harm
now there are certain things that could
be done to prevent facebook from
discriminating on the basis of politics
we've talked about those things in the
past right section 230 of the
communications decency act was intended
to provide a broader spectrum of
political viewpoints online
originally there were there were
liability concerns with anybody who
allowed third-party posters to put
material up on the internet so any
comments section of a website you could
be held liable for whatever got put up
in the comments section section 230 said
you're not liable for third-party
content that is posted on your site and
then there's a legal case in which one
of these major websites was sort of
cultivating the content that it put up
mainly to try and prevent pornography
and spam they were sued because the
argument was now they're cultivating the
content so they're responsible for the
content they were sued and they and they
lost and then the federal government
stepped in and said okay that's not
really right we should be allowing
people who cultivate content at least to
get rid of pornography for example or
spam we shouldn't make them liable for
the other content that's on their site
right this is how sites like facebook
are able to remove pornography remove
violent material remove spam
without being subjected to the same
legal regimen of liability that for
example daily wire's editorial page is
subjected to
okay then facebook started to move
beyond that and actually censor content
and nudge people in particular
directions the best way of correcting
that would be to change section 230 to
remove the catch-all provisions and just
say okay facebook is allowed to remove
pornography obscenity violent content
but they're not allowed to just remove
things on the basis of politics alone
and if they do start doing that now they
look more like the new york times or the
daily wire in terms of the liability
they undergo okay that's the right-wing
point of view on facebook the left-wing
point of view on facebook is that
facebook is bad not because it doesn't
allow enough content but because it
allows too much content the left-wing
viewpoint on facebook is that facebook
is such a dominant
place for people to get their
information that they can grab it and
they can use it to their own advantage
and democrats and the media have become
experts in this inside outside game they
now play with corporations where
somebody inside a corporation a staffer
at a corporation gains access to
confidential material and then goes and
quote unquote leaks it they're a
whistleblower right even though the
information is not illegal they take
that information that is confidential
and then they put it out there in the
public sphere with the help of the media
that have an agenda the media push it
democrats hold hearings on it and then
all of them threaten all of these social
media companies into doing what they
want
they essentially make facebook into an
agent of the democratic party
by threatening them with legislation or
regulatory oversight if they don't do
what the democratic party wants
this is incredibly dangerous stuff
whether we are talking about the free
speech area or whether we're talking
about business areas if the democratic
party is doing the same thing with
regard to major corporations which they
are you'll have a whistleblower at a
major corporation the whistleblower will
report that a corporation is doing
nothing illegal but something the
democrats don't like the media then blow
it up into a major issue the democrats
then hold hearings and they say we will
regulate you and we will come after you
and we'll find a way to punish your
business unless unless you do what we
want and so they turn private
organizations private businesses into
agents of the democratic party by using
the power of government to threaten
even though if the government actually
went forward and passed legislation
along these lines there's a good shot it
would be unconstitutional
so we'll get to how this is expressing
itself with regard to facebook and it's
super dangerous because if you think
that there ought to be a level playing
field when it comes to your access to
information that this is the core
liberty that the first amendment was
seeking to protect democrats doing this
with social media is unbelievably
dangerous they're attempting to
re-establish the media monopoly media
oligopoly that they held for 50 years
before the rise of the internet we'll
get some more of this in just one second
first we've got a very different kind of
sponsor for this episode it's the jordan
harbinger show it's a podcast you really
should be listening to i know every day
somebody tells you you just have to
listen to some podcasts and you nod you
say sure and then you never listen to it
don't let that happen here we are fans
of the jordan harbinger show here at the
daily wire jordan's show a chapel named
one of its best of 2018 is aimed at
making you a better informed more
critical thinker so you can get a sense
of how the world actually works and come
to your own conclusions about what's
happening even inside your own brain
each episode is a conversation with a
different fascinating guest when i say
there's something for everyone here i
really mean that in one episode jordan
talks to a hostage negotiator from the
fbi who offers techniques on how to get
people to like and trust you which is
both useful and pretty disturbing
another episode tells the story of a
pimp and mafia enforcer who talks about
mind manipulation techniques and how to
defend against them they're guests that
range from oliver north to kobe bryant
you don't have to agree with jordan too
recognizing what he's doing is really
interesting we here at daily where i
really enjoy the show go check it out
right now at jordanharbinger.com start
for some episode recommendations or
search for the jordan harbinger show
h-a-r-b as in boy i n is a nancy g-e-r
on apple podcast spotify or wherever you
listen to podcasts okay so
the new push against facebook which
remember this is like their third push
against facebook since 2016. right after
2016 there's a push against facebook on
the russian disinformation front ah
facebook needs to crack down on foreign
actors manipulating u.s elections
the reality as i've said before is that
the amount of actual russian
manipulation during the 2016 election
via facebook was minimal statistically
speaking then there was the push in 2018
2019 that there was too much generalized
misinformation being put out there and
facebook needed to crack down on it and
facebook reacted both both times by
trying to placate the democrats in 2018
2019 the democratic party demanded that
facebook
create some sort of answerability for
quote unquote misinformation right they
shifted from disinformation in 2016 and
2017 to misinformation in 2018 2019 and
that's when facebook started to
institute fact-checking regimes that
were designed to downgrade conservative
content and to upgrade legacy media
content because the fact checkers
themselves very often were working for
the legacy media
okay now we have reached the third stage
this is the third iteration of the
attack on facebook and this iteration is
facebook is just bad facebook is bad
because of what they do so there's this
facebook quote-unquote whistleblower i
say quote-unquote whistleblower because
she's not blowing the whistle on
anything
she literally is revealing no new
information that people did not know
like is it information that teenage
girls using instagram may not make them
mentally healthier so by self pulling
data
many teenage girls say that instagram
like 42 say instagram makes their life
better and only 15 20 say it makes their
life worse but like let's face it pretty
much every fashion show ever has made
teenage girls life's worse
teenage girls
coordinating coordinating online and
viewing pictures of beautiful people and
feeling
envy and and a certain level of bodily
discomfort by looking at at other
pictures of other this is true for
facebook it's true for twitter anytime
teenage girls are comparing themselves
to some sort of ideal this is not good
for mental health frankly online very
often it's not good for mental health
period and that's true for boys and
girls so nothing new is being revealed
by the quote unquote
she's a democratic activist who is
working at facebook and now she's being
celebrated by the media for not saying
anything new but for presumably tearing
the lid off facebook
so her name is francis hogan when i say
she's a democratic activist what i mean
is that it's pretty damned clear she's a
democratic activist
according to the daily wire she has a
record of donations to far left
democrats and a history of raising
issues about purported bias while at
previous employers
she's working with democratic operatives
to roll out her complaint she has the
same lawyers as the anonymous ukraine
whistleblower whose allegations led to
donald trump's impeachment but who
reportedly turned out to be then vice
president joe biden's top advisor in the
country
so
she is a long-time radical leftist on
january 13th 2020 for example she gave
money to alexandra ocasio-cortez she's
made more than 20 federal campaign
contributions since 2016 all of which
have gone to democrats according to the
fec
she was invited to testify by the senate
subcommittee on consumer protection
product safety and data security chaired
by radical leftist senator richard
blumenthal of connecticut
the lawyers that she has
are from a group called whistleblower
aid the group was founded by mark zaid
who previously represented the national
security official who alleged donald
trump inappropriately pressed the
ukraine president on a phone call
to investigate whether joe biden pressed
the country to drop an investigation
into burisma
hogan's case
is uh is pretty obviously being pushed
by a raft of people who have been
involved with the democratic party the
public relations from a former obama
aide bill burton a company called bryce
and gillette is providing hogan with
strategic communications device
according to the washington free beacon
shen saki by the way worked for bryce
and gillette as a senior advisor until
september 2020
but the center for human technology is
one of her clients according to ethics
filings obtained by the daily wire so
this lady is really really well
entrenched with the democratic
bureaucracy so again the game is this
find a quote-unquote whistleblower the
whistleblower doesn't blow the whistle
on anything they just say a bunch of
stuff democrats like democrats bring the
facebook whistleblower forward they have
her say a bunch of stuff we already knew
but in tones of high dungeon and then
the democrats threaten facebook with
vague regulation
and what they really want is to set up a
governmental quote unquote oversight
body that is designed not to promote any
sort of neutral standard that the
government could be held to
or that could subject or that could
subject the the government to lawsuit
for example instead they just want to
have like a specialist who sits over a
business
and want to have a shadow ceo at the
governmental level
that's the goal so here is francis hogan
saying this right she specifically asked
okay if facebook's monopoly why don't we
break it up right is that your
contention she says no no i don't want
them to be broken up i want heavy
regulations and really what i want is a
government agency that sits on top of
them and mark zuckerberg has to have a
boss appointed by the democratic party
i'm actually against the breaking up of
facebook because even looking inside of
just facebook itself so not even
facebook and instagram you see the
problems of engagement based ranking
repeat themselves
so the problems here are about the
design of algorithms of ai and the idea
that ai is not intelligent i also
believe there needs to be a dedicated
oversight body because right now the
only people in the world who are trained
to analyze these experiments to
understand what's happening inside of
facebook are people who you know grew up
inside of facebook or pinterest or
another social media company and there
needs to be a regulatory home where
someone like me could do a tour of duty
after working at a place like this
and and have a place to work on things
like regulation to bring that
information out to the oversight boards
that that have the right to do oversight
what a self-sacrificial whistleblower
she's literally saying leave facebook
intact leave it huge leave it dominant
let it retain market share and put me in
charge of it understand that's what
she's saying she's saying there ought to
be a regulatory home or someone like me
a quote unquote whistleblower can leave
facebook i was just a product manager
right they have thousands of product
managers
i could be a product man but instead of
being product manager i'll be mark
zuckerberg's boss via the democratic
party in a regulatory oversight body
where i could i could work right she
literally says that she literally says i
could leave facebook and then i could
move over to the regulatory side and
then i could tell mark zuckerberg what
to do
understand this is what democrats want
this is not about being anti-facebook
it's about being very pro facebook so
long as democrats can run it
they don't like the idea of facebook
being independently run even though
facebook does a lot of the things
democrats want but this is the point
this is true for business as well
democrats when it comes to this when it
comes to this sort of stuff
they are they're
economically fascist
okay economic fascism is corporatism
it's essentially the idea that the
federal government of
should essentially control businesses
top down in a very detailed manner and
that if these businesses work hand in
glove with the government then we leave
them alone everybody else who doesn't
work with the government those people
are screwed but if you work with the
government we'll leave you alone we'll
let you retain your market share but we
will essentially control every aspect of
how you run your business
this sort of corporatist mentality
is
obviously on display here and it's why
democrats are pushing this there is
nothing new she didn't say anything new
now the way that democrats have to
justify taking control of facebook is to
claim that facebook is quote unquote
promoting violence i remember they there
was an attempt to do this with parlor as
well which is why amazon web services
not parlor offline in the immediate
aftermath of january 6th so this
facebook whistleblower hogan she says
the that facebook is going to lead to
genocide
my fears that without action
divisive and extremist behaviors we see
today are only the beginning what we saw
in
and are now seen in ethiopia are only
the opening chapters of a story so
terrifying no one wants to read the end
of it
congress can change the rules that
facebook plays by and stop the many
harms it is now causing
we now know the truth about facebook's
destructive impact
okay this is just
i'm sorry it's top down sensorius
bullcrap
it turns out the genocide and human
polarization and people treating each
other terribly
has been a feature of human life since
as long as human beings have been on
planet earth it is not facebook which is
simply a place where people gather and
talk with each other that is causing
polarization or that is causing genocide
it is people who do these things and her
suggestion is well if we just
controlled the distribution of
information top down via the government
which has never been bad right i mean
the government has never been been used
to polarize people the government would
never ever seize control of the means of
distribution of information and start
promoting propaganda on behalf of one
political party that affected how people
vote and how people think they would
never do that i mean sure they did it
like in the last election like the whole
last month of the election when they
just sort of downgraded all conservative
traffic via social media under pressure
from democrats and also got rid of
openly true stories like the hunter by
laptop story a month before the election
but they would never do that these are
the good people we have to stop facebook
we have to stop social media this is
very reminiscent of the basic democratic
argument that is often brought up that
rights themselves are dangerous because
rights can be abused therefore the
government should get rid of the rights
you see this with regard to for example
hate speech laws that democrats are
constantly pushing
the notion that that hate speech must be
policed right because some people could
say bad things therefore the first
amendment ought to be curbed is a very
popular view on college campuses and now
it's being extended into the corporate
sphere
now as i say it's not as though this
lady is saying anything new she's not
saying anything new
according to reason.com
thanks to hogan and the wall street
journal reporting we know that facebook
attempted to serve 18 users on how
platforms were impacting their mental
health unsurprisingly the findings were
not entirely encouraging one in five
respondents said instagram made them
feel worse about themselves teens
already struggling with mental illness
said the platform was giving them a
harder time but something like 40 said
instagram made them feel better about
themselves ostensibly says reason the
problem with instagram is that it
promotes social competition the race for
likes and comments among users posting
artificial filtered images of themselves
which may exacerbate body image issues
of course there's nothing new about this
because glossy magazines have been doing
this for literal decades
okay the achievement here as reason says
is one of self-branding because hogan
did not tell us anything new about all
of this like anything as mike solana
points out quote among teenagers in a
state of mental crisis how many are
struggling with their family how many
are struggling with their friend group
or their crush how many are struggling
in a classroom so the question of does
high school make you want to kill
yourself how many suicidal teenagers
would answer yes emphatically
all of them next question when are we
dragging the secretary of education in
front of congress to explain why he
hasn't solved depression
okay again this is really just a trojan
horse for an attempt to grab control
that's all this is
for his part mark zuckerberg has
responded
he put up a facebook post and he said
that um
he he found the
the criticisms non-compelling he said
quote
first
the suv that took down all of our
services yesterday was the worst outage
that we've had in years he talked about
the the service outage that happened
with regard to facebook he's a second
now that today's testimony is over i
wanted to reflect on the public debate
we're in i'm sure many of you have found
the recent coverage hard to read because
it doesn't reflect the company we know
we care deeply about issues like safety
well-being and mental health it's
difficult to see coverage that
misrepresents our work and our motives
at the most basic level i think most of
us just don't recognize the false
picture of the company that's being
painted many of the claims don't make
sense says zuckerberg if we wanted to
ignore research why would we create an
industry-leading research program to
understand these important issues in the
first place if we didn't care about
fighting harmful content why would we
employ so many more people dedicated to
this than any other company in our space
even ones that are larger than we are if
we wanted to hide our results why would
we have established an industry-leading
standard for transparency and reporting
and if social media were as responsible
for polarizing society as some people
claim why are we still seeing
polarization increase in the us while it
stays flat or declines in many countries
with just as heavy a use of social media
around the world
we'll get to more of mark zuckerberg's
response to the accusations of the
quote-unquote issue the fake
whistleblower from from facebook in just
one second first let us talk about the
benefits of cryptocurrency so i'm a big
fan of cryptocurrency i do own bitcoin i
do own ethereum and right now you really
need to know about this brand new
company alto ira with an alto crypto ira
you can trade crypto like bitcoin and
avoid or defer the taxes it's a great
way to get into investing in crypto and
do it in a tax advantaged retirement
account
alto's crypto ira is the easy way to get
crypto into an ira you can trade all you
want without the tax headache and create
an account in as little as a few minutes
invest with as little as 10 bucks there
are no set up charges secure trading is
available 24 7 through alto's
integration with coinbase there are 80
plus coins available that includes
bitcoin ethereum and cardano if you want
some sushi swap with your bitcoin no
problem because alto has you covered as
well they've got industry leading
security the advanced encryption
standard for wallets and private keys
and multiple ways to fund your account
you make a cash contribution you can
transfer cash from an existing ira or
roll over from an old 401k it's a great
way to dip your toe into investing in
cryptocurrency which
for my buck literally before my buck is
a great way of hedging against
governmental inflation and heavy
governmental regulation open an alto
crypto ira account with as little as ten
dollars to get started just go to
altoira dot com slash ben that's
a-l-t-o-i-r-a
dot com slash ben go to alto ira dot com
and i'm a believer that at least a small
part of your portfolio should be
invested in crypto as a hedge against
inflation and as a hedge against
government interventionism go check them
out a-l-t-o-i-r-a-dot-com
ben check them out to get started right
now okay so zuckerberg is responding to
the fake facebook whistleblower he says
at the heart of these accusations is the
idea that we prioritize profit over
safety and well-being that's just not
true for example one move that has been
called into question is when we
introduced the meaningful social
interactions change to news feed this
change showed fewer viral videos and
more content from friends and family
which we did knowing it would mean
people spent less time on facebook but
that research suggested it was the right
thing for people's well-being is that
something a company focused on profits
over people would do the argument we
deliberately push content that makes
people angry for profit is illogical we
make money from ads advertisers
consistently tell us they don't want
their ads next to harmful or angry
content i don't know any tech company
that sets out to build products that
make people angry or depressed the moral
business and product incentives all
point in the opposite direction
but of everything published says
zuckerberg i'm particularly focused on
the questions raised about our work with
kids i've spent a lot of time reflecting
on the kinds of experiences i want my
kids and others to have online and it's
very important to me everything we build
is safe and good for kids the reality is
young people use technology think about
how many school-age kids have phones now
listen i actually believe that kids very
often should not be given phones by
their parents i don't plan on giving my
kids any sort of phone with internet
access until they basically hit 17 18
years old but that's up to parents
rather than ignoring this technology
companies should build experiences that
meet their needs while also keeping them
safe says zuckerberg we're deeply
committed to doing industry-leading work
in this area a good example of this work
is messenger kids which is widely
recognized as better and safer than the
alternatives
we've also worked on bringing this kind
of age-appropriate experience with
parental controls for instagram as well
but given questions about whether that
would be better for kids we've paused
that project like many of you i found it
difficult to read the
mischaracterization of the research into
how instagram affects young people as we
wrote in our newsroom post explaining
this the research actually demonstrated
many teens we heard from feel using
instagram helps them when they are
struggling with the kinds of hard
moments and issues teenagers have always
faced
in fact in 11 of 12 areas on the slide
referenced by the wall street journal
including areas like loneliness anxiety
sadness and eating issues more teenage
girls who said they struggled with that
issue also said instagram made those
difficult times better rather than worse
and then zuckerberg
makes a mistake he says that we should
really let the government get involved
it's similar to balancing other social
issues i don't believe private companies
should make all the decisions on their
own that's why we have advocated for
updated internet regulations for several
years now i've testified in congress
multiple times i've asked them to update
the regulations i've written op-eds
outlining the areas of regulation we
think are most important we're committed
to doing the best work we can but at
some level the right body to assess
trade-offs between social equities is
our democratically elected congress
and what i think zuckerberg does not
understand here is that the goal of the
democrats is never to actually regulate
the goal is not to pass a law the goal
is not to create some sort of standard
by which facebook can be held
accountable the goal is to just control
facebook top down that is the goal the
goal is to take the biggest companies in
america
whether you're talking about just the
pure corporate sector or whether you're
talking about social media and to have
democrats control every aspect of how
work works this is the reason why
wokeness has infused corporations these
corporations know that if they please
democrats democrats will pat them on the
head and call them good little boys and
girls and then give them cookies
and when it comes to facebook it's not
enough for facebook to try and serve its
governmental masters in the democratic
party the democrats understand that
facebook being a place where billions of
eyeballs are gathered is a heavy threat
to their dominance via legacy media
right that is the reason we are doing
all of this the reason we are doing if
there were no facebook news feed the
democrats would not care about facebook
this would not be an issue
the reason that the democrats care about
facebook is because they want to control
the news that you see they want to
control the content you are able to
access that is their goal it's why
they're consistently putting pressure on
these giant social media companies the
news feed by the way represents a tiny
slice of facebook's actual profit
hey like
i know this for a fact the amount of of
profit and revenue represented by the
news feed from facebook is my newt
compared to the other areas of revenue
i mean the vast majority of highly
trafficked posts on facebook have
nothing to do with the news many of them
are like cat memes like people sharing
silly memes with their friends or ideas
with their friends
the reason the democrats are focusing on
the news feed is because that's what
they care about
and you can see this and how the media
are ecstatic over all of this
robin gibbon the senior critic at large
for the washington post has a piece
today in the washington post titled the
whistleblower came to advocate for
humans over algorithms
facebook needs to be less twitchy this
digital monster that has taught the
culture how to overreact and fly off the
handle needs to be tamed regulate it
open it up slow it down make it more
human
a hard intervention is like taking a
piece of content off facebook taking a
user off facebook soft interventions are
about making a slightly different choice
to make the platform less viral less
twitchy said francis hogan the former
facebook employee who testified as a
whistleblower
hogan came to offer testimony about the
way in which facebook's profit strategy
makes young people's lives worse okay
first of all i just want to point
something out whenever people on the
left talk about the evils of profit
strategy understand that human beings
are driven by ambition they're driven by
what is in their self-interest and
whenever people on the left say profit
is bad profit of course being simply the
marginal increase of value
the the risk that you took and that paid
off with regard to giving a profit or
with regard to giving a product or
service to somebody else when they say
profit is bad the alternative is the
government setting the rules what are
the incentive structures there the
incentive structures there are not about
pleasing anybody else it's about
pleasing core constituencies and not
pleasing consumers
right
if you seek to get rid of profit what is
going to be the actual driving factor in
human behavior
the actual driving factor in human
behavior is going to be soft societal
approval or levels of power and control
that you can utilize over other human
beings without having to answer to a
feedback loop like the market
the reason that profit
the reason that profit motive is good is
because it is a feedback loop where you
learn what people want and what they
don't the reason that the government is
very bad at this stuff is because
feedback loops do not exist for the
government particularly in the
regulatory sphere at least you can make
the argument that if a legislator does
something bad people can get rid of the
legislator this is not true in the
regulatory sphere so when you hear
people ripping on profit motive at
facebook understand that the alternative
is you have governmental actors who are
not answerable to you controlling major
areas of your life for their own power
and glorification that is the
alternative
and that's exactly what the washington
post would like
facebook's technology encourages some of
our worst and most dangerous tendencies
says this columnist for the washington
post
for any senator who wanted to argue that
the world would be a better place if
facebook had a smaller footprint hogan
disagreed
hogan essentially shrugged off the
concern that conservative views were
being downgraded
saying that this was a digression
of course because hogan doesn't want
conservative views she doesn't want more
speech she wants less speech she wants
democrats to control your speech
okay the goal here is to prevent people
from actually coordinating with one
another and talking with one another
this is why anderson cooper was gushing
on cnn the overwhelming media
love for this whistleblower should be
telling you something maybe it should be
telling you something about
self-interest
facebook likes to say it was built to
bring people together it literally uses
those words and promotional material
well today it did bring people together
for the first time in a long time
democratic and republican members of a
senate commerce subcommittee were
together united in their praise of
whistleblower francis haugen now as you
know she's the former facebook product
manager who leaked tens of thousands of
pages of internal documents indicating
that facebook knows the harm that they
and instagram can do
but chooses to put clicks eyeballs and
ad sales ahead of fixing the problem
okay but there's no way to fix the
problem this is the point that
zuckerberg has made what problem are you
trying to fix and how would a regulation
fix it no one has proposed anything
other than francis haugen saying i
should run literally saying i should run
facebook
okay that's what it comes down to and
the reason that i'm very passionate
about this is because i prefer open
platforms my criticism of facebook is
they haven't allowed enough control by
the user they've allowed too much
control by the people at the top of
facebook
in in terms of nudging you francis
hallgan wants the government to nudge
you via the use of facebook that is the
goal here and the media are into it
they're into it wholeheartedly because
they want their monopoly reestablished
this is a selfish play on i'm part of
the media this is not an unselfish
attempt to protect teenage girls that's
not what the media are into that is not
what they care about what they care
about is preventing the dissemination of
information that the media oppose
and by the way the reason that the media
the medium this is a problem of the
media's own creation if they wanted to
re-establish faith with the american
public they could stop being dishonest
jackasses but they're not going to stop
doing that so instead they're going to
try and seize control of again how you
get your news we'll get to more of this
in just one second
you know life is filled with surprises
and difficulties and let's say that
you're hired as a lawyer by a major
corporation this corporation was into
scientific research and they thought
about what could they do rather than
what should they do and so they decided
they were going to create let's say like
a giant park and you're a lawyer for
this corporation and one day you were at
this giant park and suddenly the
dinosaurs showed up and so you ran and
you were hiding and you were
you know it was a difficult time for you
you ran into the toilet and suddenly the
jaws of a t-rex began to close around
you at that point you might think to
yourself wow
i should have gotten life insurance well
have you ever had that thought you
should be having it now policy genius
can help make that happen for you policy
genius makes it easy to compare quotes
from over a dozen top insurers all in
one place why compare you could save 50
or more on life insurance by comparing
quotes with policy genius
in fact you could save 1300 or more per
year on life insurance by using policy
genius to compare policies the licensed
experts and policy genius work for you
not the insurance companies so you can
trust them to help you navigate every
step of the shopping and buying process
that kind of service has earned policy
genius thousands of five star reviews
across trustpilot and google and
eligible applicants can get covered in
as little as a week thanks to an
award-winning policy option that swaps
the standard medical exam requirement
for a simple phone call this exclusive
policy was recently rated number one by
forbes advisor higher than options from
ladder ethos and bestow getting started
super simple first head on over to
policygenius.com shapiro in minutes you
can work out how much life insurance
coverage you need and compare
personalized quotes to find your best
price head on over to policygenius.com
get started right now that's policy
genius when it comes to insurance it's
nice and quite important to get it right
okay so as i say the media are fully
invested in the bullcrap facebook
whistleblower who's not blowing the
whistle on anything because they want to
leverage their power
for control on behalf of democrats is
why you have allison camerata who's
berating the facebook facebook employees
thing you allowed the big lie to pro
proliferate you allowed it to prol what
do you mean you allowed it to
proliferate it's an open platform
facebook is not responsible for
third-party content that's posted on
facebook that's literally the entire
principle of facebook existing but
according to allison camerata it is
facebook's problem and facebook's fault
if people disagree on election fraud
what about democracy does facebook take
any responsibility for what happened on
january 6th since it allowed the big
election lie propagated by donald trump
to proliferate on the site
the responsibility for january 6 i can't
be more clear about this than to say the
responsibility for january 6 lies with
those who broke the law and those in
politics and elsewhere who incited them
okay the facebook spokesperson is
exactly right okay the her name is
bickert okay she's exactly correct but
note like has anyone ever cnn does cnn
bear responsibility for the riots that
happened last summer when they were
allowing the big lie that police across
the country are systematically racist to
not only proliferate but fill their news
waves for day after day after day for
year after year actually does cnn bear
responsibility for that should we
regulate cnn on that and cnn by the way
is an editorial it's an editorial
company and now imagine that cnn weren't
an editorial company or just a bunch of
people posting stuff
okay would they be responsible is att
responsible for january 6th because some
people use the phone to talk to each
other
okay the goal here is to take control it
is about control it is always about
control
is why you have senator ed markey
who is
an out-and-out totalitarian when it
comes to governmental control of
business
talking to francis haugen and and and
openly threatening mark zuckerberg
here's my message for mark zuckerberg
your time of invading our privacy
promoting toxic content and preying on
children and teens is over
congress will be taking action you can
work with us
on not work with us but we will not
allow
your company to harm our children and
our families and our democracy any
longer
okay notice what he says our children
our family and our democracies first of
all parents have the ability to turn off
facebook and instagram
our families parents have the ability
this is a parental thing and then when
it comes to our democracy this is what
mark is talking about what harms the
democracy according to ed marky is the
first amendment what harms the democracy
is your ability to access sites like the
daily wire via the facebook news feed
all of this is just a cover it is all
just a bs cover for the actual seizure
of power david sicilian the
representative from louisiana he's
openly saying that facebook needs to
turn over its algorithms to the federal
government now
if
facebook
comes up with a proprietary algorithm
that enhances their business
capabilities they don't seem to think
they have to share that how do you make
them share that
well i mean there's a number of ways you
can require algorithmic audits to be
sure they're doing what they claim they
do you can require greater transparency
for algorithms you can you know permit
agent an agency responsible looking at
their practices either it's impact on
competition or on fairness to consumers
or to obvious places
okay under what rubric would you seize
their algorithms
really under what rubric
i i know of very few other situations in
american life where you are simply
supposed to turn over your confidential
business information to the federal
government so they can oversee you
not because you're like flying an
airplane around and and you need to
demonstrate that the airplane is going
to fly to the faa but because you're
just a business operating the the point
here is that you cannot demand that
corporations turn over all confidential
business information under the open
acknowledgement that you are attempting
to violate the first amendment
that's a wild thing to do
but that's exactly what they want that
is the goal here why so they can
re-establish that monopoly so they can
continue to push forward their actual
agenda it's always agenda uber alice
we'll get to what that agenda is these
days in just one moment first let's talk
about grand canyon university so i
visited grand canyon university it's a
wonderful place the student body is
fantastic it's a beautiful campus and
they're focused in on teaching people
about things that actually matter the
ben shapiro show is proud to be
sponsored by grand canyon university
it's an affordable christian university
one of the largest fastest growing
universities in the country it's located
in sunny phoenix arizona gcu is ranked
top 20 for best college campuses in
america it offers over 275 engaging
academic programs with over 240 online
gcu integrates the free market system
with a welcoming christian worldview
perspective into its academic programs
so you can put your faith into action
and help transform your community in
2020 gcu students received over 290
million bucks in scholarships with many
attending gcu for less than the cost of
a state university find your purpose at
gcu private christian affordable i
really think that you cannot afford to
send your kid or yourself to a
university that isn't going to at least
mirror some eternal values at this point
considering what universities have
become factories of leftist thought that
is not so at gcu visit gcu.edu
my offer to see what scholarships you
qualify for alrighty in just one second
we'll get to the democratic agenda being
pushed by the media right now first
in a world full of hyperbole and
propaganda you deserve the straight up
fact that's why we started our newest
podcast morning wire which has been
topping the apple and spotify charts
since its recent release it's the only
daily news podcast that values your time
and the truth and while we're working
overtime to bring you the news you need
to know we need your help to keep the
facts trending toward number one so
subscribe and start listening now to
morning wire on apple spotify or
wherever you listen to podcasts leave a
five star review if you like what you
hear you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
now the reason that the democrats in the
media want to re-establish the oligopoly
in terms of
informational dissemination is twofold
one for the media marketplace
they would love control they would love
to maintain their former levels of
control because as the media space
fragments and as people start to view
podcasts like this one or start to
listen to shows like this one or start
to access the daily wire that means less
control over how you get your news and
less money for them and they actually
want their narrative to win and that
narrative is so often at odds with
reality that the only way their
narrative can win is to shut down the
dissemination of the opposing narrative
so for example you've been hearing that
joe biden is still in control of things
i'm sorry joe biden is not with us he
has not been with us for a very long
time for like a year you were told that
if you ever questioned joe biden's
mental health it was because there was
something wrong with you okay joe biden
is not even speaking english anymore he
is not englishing
okay joe biden is not with us here is
joe biden again this is like the middle
of the day guys this isn't 7 p.m after
he's had a long day hard at work in the
oval office or something this is like
2 50 p.m central time yesterday and the
man is slurring his words and walking
into things
when you build a charging station it's
like back in the day when my grandpop
worked for the american oil company back
in the tournament in the
1920 in that area they went from state
to state convincing people that they put
allow them to put 20 000 gallons of
gasoline under the ground they didn't
want them around
i'm sorry this is embarrassing
it is you should be embarrassed as an
american by this i know there are a lot
of people who are embarrassed by how
trump talked
trump actually completed sentences
sometimes
joe biden i never thought that i would
be favorably comparing donald trump's
rhetorical prowess with a future
president but that's
i mean job it's like they
play hail to the cheetah
president joseph r biden there's him in
the corn
and drew the rich yay
what in the hell what in the hell it
didn't stop there by the way the
babbling just continues like what
it feels like you are walking the halls
of an insane asylum at this point
they believe
they they they believe they'll win
they'll win the day and they can dictate
their way forward and leave us behind
they're betting not a joke
they're betting for the first time we
won't respond to this inflection point
in history
that will fail to rise at the occasion
but you've heard me say it a lot of
times
it's never ever been a good bet to get
back to bed against the american people
never
it's never been gone
yeah here's the thing the american
people see through biden his poll
numbers suck they suck for a reason
according to politico democrats who are
hoping that the monthly 300 per child
checks the federal government started
sending to families over the summer
would be a winner in the midterms they
won't like the findings of the latest
morning console poll fewer than half of
respondents 47 gave congressional
democrats any credit for providing the
extra cash even fewer 38
credited joe biden while half of
registered voters support the expanded
payments versus 38 percent in opposition
only 35 want to make them permanent
which is what democrats are trying at
the moment democrats just want to cram
down the idea that they will give you
free money and that you will love it you
will love the free money that they are
cramming down upon you
and in order to justify spending all
this money of course they're going to
claim that the republicans are
obstructionist because republicans won't
voluntarily raise the debt ceiling okay
here's the thing the debt ceiling right
is a way to pry concessions as far as
future spending plans out of the hands
of democrats that is the goal here that
is what republicans are trying to do
they're saying listen we understand
you're trying to pay off the current
credit card bill also we are not going
to extend you a further line of credit
unless you decide that you're going to
restructure how you approach the economy
as a whole
but democrats don't want to do that and
here's the thing democrats don't even
want to be held accountable on all of
this
so joe biden is is fulminating over the
debt ceiling we're supposed to hit the
debt ceiling in a couple of weeks
democrats have every ability today to
pass a debt ceiling bill they can do it
literally today
and they can do what is called a
vote-a-rama and they can do it today
but joe biden is trying to blame this on
republicans
he's saying that it's true you know the
big problem here is that trump was a big
spender as i recall all the spending
done last year was a bipartisan affair
including democrats all the spending
done this year was a completely partisan
affair with not a single republican vote
so far as i'm aware here is joe biden
here ripping on trump
the reason we have to raise the debt
limit is in part because of the reckless
tax and spending policies under the
previous trump administration
in four years
they incurred that incurred nearly eight
trillion dollars
in four years eight trillion dollars in
additional debt
in bills we have to now pay off
that's more than a quarter of the entire
debt incurred now outstanding
after more than 200 years
okay and then biden continues along
these lines and gets catastrophic well
it's gonna be it's gonna be the end of
the subject
we're gonna do this here we go
not only are republicans refusing to do
their job
but threatening reuse the power their
power to prevent us from doing our job
saving the economy from a catastrophic
event
i think quite frankly hypocritical
dangerous and disgraceful
their obstruction and their
responsibility knows absolutely no
bounds
excuse me especially
as we're clawing our way out of this
pandemic
okay and then he finishes up by saying
if you don't want to save the country
get the hell out of the way because
there's nothing that says bipartisanship
quite like that
meteor has had is headed to crash into
our economy
democrats are willing to do all the work
stopping it
republicans just have to let us do our
job
just get out of the way
you don't want to help save the country
get out of the way
so you don't destroy it okay they aren't
in the way democrats can pass a debt
ceiling relief bill any single anytime
they want they have 50 votes
they can do it via reconciliation joe
biden doesn't want to do that because
that would involve a quote unquote voter
rama okay voter rama is where the
democrats have to vote on a bunch of
separate issues and they all have to be
on the record voting for those separate
issues biden doesn't want them on the
record so he's angry at republicans
that's all this is
the media would love to
the media would love to be able to cram
down narratives like that one without
anybody being any the wiser that is the
end goal here okay speaking of the
generalized joe biden policy on the
economy the democrats are at this point
talking about just ridiculous crap so
the debt ceiling is scheduled to again
democrats anytime they want can do what
is called a voterama and they can vote
through a debt ceiling provision
simply by majority vote through
reconciliation they do not need a single
republican vote to pass reconciliation
at this point that's it okay but instead
they are now considering the just to
avoid the culpability of having to vote
on a bunch of single issues at the
senate level
and then hold those senators to account
to avoid all of that the democrats are
now apparently contemplating the
stupidity of minting a trillion-dollar
platinum coin
according to axios
a trillion dollar platinum coin could be
minted within hours of the treasury
secretary's decision to do so says
philip diehl former director of the u.s
mint
congressional solutions to the debt
ceiling problem could take weeks to
implement especially if reconciliation
is used and time is running out well
then you guys better get on it shouldn't
you
in case of emergency a trillion dollar
coin could be deployed to bridge any gap
between the money running out and the
debt ceiling being raised
us mint already produces a one-ounce
platinum eagle and has no shortage of
platinum blanks already in stock so
first of all i'm just looking forward to
the netflix film about the ragtag group
of diverse criminals who steal the 1
trillion fed coin that has now been
created in order to pay off our
ballooning national debt
apparently a coin could be struck in
minutes at the west appointment
and then it would be physically
deposited at the new york fed and voila
you have bought yourself the equivalent
of a trillion dollar increase in the
debt limit without any impact on
inflation well i mean there is some
impact on inflation considering that
when you start minting coins in order to
pay off the debt which is what you're
talking about right here
the idea being we'll backfill all of
this later
and then take the one trillion dollar
coin out of circulation
the when you start doing that you are
leading the way to what if we just print
more money what if we actually just
physically print more money that's
clearly what is why people have been
hesitant to do this in the past
but according to the democrats the real
idea here should be to get rid of the
debt limit entirely entirely here's
james clyburn making that case
we have some arcade rules
that we need to just get rid of this
debt limit business is archaic and needs
to be uh thrown
to the trash pile
okay it needs to be thrown in the trash
pile we won't have to remember the way
that it used to be is that congress
actually had to appropriate specific
funds congress had to tell the federal
government exactly what debt instruments
they had to use this was the case from
about 1987 all the way through about
1910 okay and then during world war one
there were these sort of blanket
abilities for the federal government to
take out debt and then in the 1970s
there was an attempt to effectively get
rid of the debt ceiling by saying
anytime congress appropriated funding
that would give the federal treasury the
ability to take out debt and then that
was walked back in the 1990s
that's what the democrats would like
back they would like the idea to be that
we never have to think about the debt
ever ever ever it just automatically
increases the ability of the federal
government to borrow and then they
wonder why people are worried about
inflation
janet yellen again it is incredible and
it says something
about how our financial system works
that people move directly from the
so-called independent federal reserve
directly over to heading the treasury
department for joe biden without any gap
and they promote exactly the same policy
we're gonna pretend that's not political
in any way here is janet yellen saying
that inflation is transitory but also
it's not going to go away soon which is
not the definition of transitory
supply bottlenecks have developed um
that have caused inflation i believe
that they're transitory but that doesn't
mean they'll go away over the next
several months
oh it'll go well if it goes away then
but it's also not it's kind of
transitory but not also she wants more
control over how you do your finances so
the democrats have been proposing an irs
rule that would require all banks to
report all transactions over six hundred
dollars so that the irs can can spy on
everything you do six hundred dollars
they're not talking about ten thousand
dollars now twenty thousand not five
thousand dollars that's 600 bucks okay
you're talking about like taking out
cash for a couple nights at a hotel
there is here's janet yellen saying that
the irs should be empowered to audit
basically every transaction you do
automatically right banks will
automatically be forced to report all
transactions over six 600
because there's
regulators should control your life they
should
a simple way for the irs to get a sense
of where that might be is just a few
pieces of information about individuals
bank accounts
nothing at the transaction level that
would violate privacy simply aggregate
inflows into the account over the year
and aggregate outflows
oh okay that great great just the irs
should have more control
yeah all of this is about more control
top down and this is why they have to
maintain the supremacy of informational
dissemination if that goes away they got
a real problem on their hands okay
meanwhile democrats have begun to narrow
their differences on biden's social
spending bill as i predicted this thing
is not going to go down to flaming
defeat eventually it will end up in the
2 trillion area according to the
washington post democrats in a flurry of
private talks are beginning to narrow
their differences over the size of
biden's sweeping safety net bill as
liberals signal they are open to
sizeable concessions on the scope of
what could be the most far-reaching
social legislation in years i mean guys
stop tubing all over the place that's
some serious journalism hot hot sticky
journalism most far-reaching social
legislation in years
the discussions which remain highly
fluid suggest that democratic leaders
are pushing to move beyond a series of
angry intra-party standoffs and focus
instead on whether they can coalesce
around a scaled-down package in a
virtual meeting with a dozen liberal
democrats on monday biden suggested a
package in the range of 1.9 trillion to
2.2 trillion for the safety net bill
significantly lower than the original
3.5 trillion still a massive bill for
militia paul countered with a range of
2.5 trillion to 2.9 trillion according
to three of those people
biden signaled another potential
compromise when asked by reporters
whether he would sign the bill if it
included the hyde amendment a provision
banning the use of federal funds for
abortion right that is a writer that is
attached pretty much every federal bill
and biden said yeah i'll still sign that
which is fun since last year he said he
opposed the height amendment
biden is also attempting to tell people
how important this bill is when we are
in the middle of an inflationary spiral
and we are paying people to stay out of
work and there are 10 million open jobs
in the country right now
and democrats are a little bit damned if
they do damned if they don't here if
they don't do it then they are incapable
of getting anything done and if they do
do it then they are going to end up with
a bill that is going to provide just a
field day for republicans ripping on how
democrats spend your money
so there's only one way that you can get
through that the only way there's no way
out but through for the democrats and
that is they just have to keep talking
if they keep talking they have to fill
the airwaves and they have to prevent
anybody from speaking back against them
okay this is true in the area of fiscal
responsibility is also true in the area
of science
it is just a continuing incredible thing
to me
how the
scientific establishment has been
completely perverted by a desire for
social justice nonsense it's insane so
yesterday there was a meme that was
going around it wasn't even me it was it
was a thing from health line right
health line is a medical website and
here's what health line is now saying is
under parenthood at pregnancy can men
get pregnant
is it possible
yes according to health line it's
possible for men to become pregnant and
give birth to children of their own in
fact it's probably a lot more common
than you might think in order to explain
we'll need to break down some common
misconceptions about how we understand
how we understand the term man
uh so
um
no we don't you mean the misconception
that's been held by all of humanity
since the dawn of time because human
species is a sexually dichotomous
species that is the basis for all human
reproduction
i mean if men can get pregnant i will
say that the birthing process via the
urethra is going to be extraordinarily
painful
you think it's bad through the vaginal
canal try it through the urethra
um
no men cannot get pregnant but our
scientific experts are now telling us so
the only way that you can promote
garbage is again to hold an
informational monopoly that is the only
way you can do it
and that's how you end up with this
insane situation with sonic so
there's this insane story that made the
rounds yesterday again this just
demonstrates it demonstrates at full
scale how crazy our society has become
there is a recent viral video of a trans
woman in a heated conversation with a
sonic employee and it sparked a debate
about gender identity and transphobia
here is the video and then sonic said
they would investigate because everyone
is a damned coward here is the video
okay but your entire staff has been
calling me sir the entire time okay
what about me looks like a sir right now
if they call you a sir i don't know what
they did then because they saw the name
on my credit card and they were being
they were not being nice people well i
mean that's what your name on the card
guy what do you want whether one what do
you want them to tell you
that has nothing to do with it
there could be someone in the back that
they don't see
that's paying okay ma'am so why would
they intentionally do that can you tell
me what your location has done to be
transcompetent because clearly they are
not
okay so the entire the entire video is
about a person
who's complaining because this person's
credit card apparently has a male name
on it and people called the person sir
and then this person got angry
so taurus says i demand to be given
respect when it comes to my gender
identity i refuse to let a cisgender
heteronormative world dominate my
existence i and any other trans person
fighting for trans liberation is doing
so to make the world a more inclusive
and equitable world for us as my friend
lola famously said we aren't working
with a broken system we're working with
the system that was never in place for
trans and gender expansive humans i
don't want the sonic manager fired that
would do no good he would be transphobic
the next place he works he deserves the
chance to leave i want all businesses to
hire translate organizations to teach
their employees how to respect all
humans
so sonic immediately looked into this
and
started thinking about whether they
ought to fire this person for the great
crime of pointing out that perhaps the
employees were terming this person sir
because the person's credit card had a
male name on it
it's just it's unbelievable
okay and at one point the employee asked
so what are you can i call you sir or
ma'am
and torah says what would you assume
looking at me and the sonic employee
answers i assume you're a man
and that's when taurus turned the camera
to face himself displaying pink lipstick
long hair and cat iframes and said thank
you whatever and drove away
okay well if you ask somebody whether
they appear to be a man or a woman
and then they give you an honest answer
that is not transphobia if you are a man
i'm sorry it isn't you're a biological
man but again the only way that you can
promote this sort of crap and then you
can do it to corporations
and then you can do it to the entire
society
is by essentially monopolizing the
conversation
i keep focusing on that because it's so
important the monopoly on the
conversation is everything to the left
if they lose the monopoly on
conversation they lose the conversation
they know it we all know it
that's what's behind the facebook
crackdown
it's what is behind the corporate woke
pressure
it is all about monopolizing the
conversation and shutting down dissent
that's what it's about in the end all
right we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content in
the meantime go check out the michael
moles show that is available right now
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben spiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pavo
wiedowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
an australian state has citizens sending
selfies to the government to prove they
haven't left their homes the cdc floats
another virtual thanksgiving quote
unquote and most millionaires don't want
to leave money to their lazy kids i
don't blame them check it out on the
michael knowles show
[Music]